we're on test 8 section 5 page 855.
problem one
if x
over x minus 2
is equal to
over
then what does x equal and here you
could try to solve this equation but
there's just a pattern here that you can
actually identify immediately if x is 39
then what is x minus 2 x minus 2 is
going to be 37 so you can immediately
just try out these numbers and that just
kind of struck you because 37 is 2 less
than 39 x minus 2 is 2 less than x so x
must be 39 and you could do that problem
really fast
if you don't understand what i'm saying
you could kind of solve it in the
traditional method cross multiply you
could say 37 times x 37 x
is equal to 39
times x minus 2
is equal to 39 times x minus 2 and so
you get 37
x is equal to 39
x minus
what is that minus 78
and then you can take
you could
subtract 39x from both sides and you get
minus 2x is equal to minus 78
divide both sides by 2 and you get x is
equal to 39. but that would have taken a
lot of valuable time and the quick the
first problem on any section of the sct
if you can't do it in 10 seconds you
might be doing it the wrong way they
normally it's normally a very very quick
problem and that's why you probably
this probably was not the correct way of
doing it you could have just said well x
is 39 x minus 2 is 37
next problem
problem two
students in advanced biology class okay
so they have boys
girls
total
boys girls total
and then on this side
and the this juniors
seniors
and then total and then they write
something they say it's k
in the table above each letter
represents the number of students in
that category right k would be the
number of junior boys in the advanced
biology class
which of the following must be equal to
z
must be equal to z so z is the total
number of kids right
so there's a couple of things that could
be equal to z
it could be
w plus x right maybe that's not a choice
it could also be
m plus t
but that's not a choice either right m
plus t isn't a choice
and the other way is you could just add
up all of the kids that are in each of
the
you know categories so you know z is the
total of all the kids so if you say the
number of junior boys plus senior boys
plus
junior girls plus senior girls so that's
k
plus n plus r plus s that's all the girl
all the all the students
in the class right and that must equal z
and that is choice e
next problem
see they have a line here like that
and then what do they tell us they tell
us that this right here
is 25 degrees
25 degrees this is a
b
c
this is 60 degrees
and this is x
and the triangle abc above what is the
value of x this is just the angle game
so the first thing we want to figure out
is this angle
and we know that this angle plus 60 is
going to be 180 right because it's
supplementary they kind of combine to
form 180 degrees or to kind of create a
line or go halfway around the circle so
this has to be 120
right because this plus 60 is 180
and then we see that 25 plus 120 plus x
have to be 180 because they're all in
the same triangle so 25
plus 120
plus x is going to be equal to 180 as
well
so 1
plus x is equal to 180
subtract 145 from both sides you get x
is equal to 35 right 80 minus 45 35
right 35 and that's choice c
next problem
problem four
the martin's refrigerator is broken and
will cost three hundred dollars to fix
three hundred dollars to fix a new
energy efficient refrigerator
costing nine hundred dollars so let's
say this other refrigerator costs nine
hundred dollars
it'll save 15 a month on the electric
bill 15 per month on the electric bill
if they buy the new refrigerator in x
months the martins will have saved an
amount equal to the difference between
the cost of the new refrigerator and the
cost of the old one what is the value of
x
okay so they're saying that in x months
this new refrigerator
they're saying
if an x must marginal have saved an
amount equal to the difference between
the cost of the new refrigerator and the
cost of fixing the old one so what's the
cost of the new refrigerator it's 900.
and what's the cost of the old of fixing
the old one it's 300
so that's the difference between the
cost of fixing the new refrigerator and
the cost of fixing the old one and they
say that that's how much they will have
saved in x months so they're going to
save that in x months they say 15 a
month right
so 15
times x months has to be equal to this
this the difference in price essentially
of fixing or buying and this is a times
not a minus times so you get what 600
is equal to 15x
see so x is equal to 600 over 15.
so x is equal to
40 right 15 goes into 64 times it goes
into 640 times so that's choice d takes
40 months for them to break even
next problem
problem five
the perimeter of an equilateral triangle
abc
is three times the perimeter of the
equilateral triangle def let me draw
them real fast so this is
it's one of them
and the other one actually is smaller
so if i call if i call this one
a b
c this one is d
e
d e f
they say the perimeter of this one is
three times this one and they're both
equilateral right so this is x x x
and so we don't know what these sides
are but the perimeter of this one will
be 3x
oh and then they tell us if the
perimeter of def is 10 what is the
length of one side of abc
so perimeter
of triangle def
is equal to 10
and they tell us that abc the perimeter
of abc is three times this right so that
means that the perimeter of triangle
abc
is going to be 3 times this
so it's 30
right so the perimeter of this triangle
is 30 and it's three equal sides so each
side has to be 10
right 30 divided by three
and that's choice
b
next problem
invert problem six
a machine mints coins at the rate of one
coin per second one coin per second
if it does this for 10 hours each day
10 hours
a day
approximately how many days will it take
the machine to mint 360 000 coins 360
000 how many days so let's say how much
how much does it produce in one day
so let's see in one day
one day
is equal to
so it'll it'll be producing for 10 hours
10 hours per day
times how many
seconds per hour
right times
600 seconds per hour
and how do i get 3 60 minutes per hour
times 60 seconds per minute right that
gives you 3 600
times
1 coin per second and the units actually
cancel out right the hours cancel out
with hours
and then you get
seconds cancel out with seconds you're
left with coins per day
so
that equals 10 times 3 600 is 36 1 2 add
another zero 36 000 coins per day coins
per day
right
so the amount of coins i produce in d
days is going to be
times d right times the number of days
and that we're saying has to be equal to
360 000.
immediately let's divide both sides well
you could d will be
360 360 000
divided by 36
and so that cancels out with that you
have 360 divided by 36
well that's just equal to 10.
so it will take 10 days to produce 360
000 coins and that's choice a i'll see
in the next video